[musique] Edgar Morin. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Je suis né en 1921 à Paris
et je suis directeur de recherche
émérite au CRS.
J'ai fait une [soupir]
j'ai eu une vie un peu aventureuse
jusqu'à ce que je sois devenu directeur
de enfin que chercheur au CNRS où j'ai
fait ma carrière
et puis beaucoup d'autres choses mais
qui prendraient beaucoup de temps.
En 1946
vous avez été chef du bureau de la
propagande du gouvernement militaire
français. Oui.
Ça consiste en quoi ?
Alors, tout d'abord, en effet, j'avais
rejoint la première armée qui entrait en
Allemagne
et
à l'étatmajor de la première armée et
une fois que la paix avait été établie,
la victoire,
c'est la la zone française est passée
entre les mains d'un gouvernement
militaire.
Et là, j'étais chargé de la propagande.
Ça consistait en quoi ? Et ben, écoutez,
moi je faisais des petites affichettes
avec des citations des grands auteurs
humanistes allemands comme Gut,
comme Novalis,
comme Valter Bamin ou autres qui
exaltait la liberté, les valeurs
humanistes et cetera. En somme,
j'essayais de d'inculquer, d'apporter,
sans faire de de l'endoctrinement, mais
des pensées. Euh je faisais des par
exemple pour le 1er mai, j'ai fait faire
des affiches où je voyais des bah qui se
libéraient de le chaîn et cetera pour
c'est frais l'émancipation des
travailleurs. Enfin bref, et surtout
personnellement, je cherchais beaucoup
les antinazis euh qui qui avaient
survécu, qui était se trouvait pas
seulement au zone française
mais dans toute l'Allemagne. Et je dois
dire aussi que j'étais ému par une sorte
de curiosité
de voir ce pays qui dont les villes
étaient détruites, rabagées.
Je voulais aller à Berlin et Berlin
était un monceau de de ruine et je
m'interrogeais sur la mentalité des
Allemands à cette époque qui était
encore avait subi l'endoctrinement nazi,
n'arrivait pas à croire ce que disaient
les alliés. Enfin et du reste ça m'a
poussé à écrire mon premier livre qui
s'appelle l'enzéro de l'Allemagne et qui
était une sorte de reportage
sociologique sur ce pays-là à ce
moment-là. Mais je dois dire aussi que
moi dans dans la quand je fais la
résistance
euh j'ai fait la résistance contre le
nazisme et jamais je n'étais antiboche.
Je veux dire, j'ai horreur de ces mots
péjoratifs pour les étrangers même s'ils
sont des des occupants. Et donc si vous
voulez, j'étais
[gémissement]
j'espérais dans des forces de
résurrection démocratique de l'Allemagne
et du reste un article qui apparu dans
des revues allemandes à l'époque qui
s'appelait Notre collaboration pour
montrer que cette collaboration qu'on
propose est d'un type tout à fait
différent que celle qu'imposait les
Allemands sous l'occupation aux Français
que c'était une une collaboration pour
fraternellement faire renaître la
démocratie. Bref, si vous voulez, j'ai
fait ce cette expérience grâce à ce
poste qui me donnait beaucoup de de
liberté et quand j'ai écrit mon livre,
je suis revenu en France.
Maintenant, avec toute cette expérience,
toute toute cette expérience que vous
avez mené pendant pratiquement un
siècle, vous avez 97 ans,
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
maintenant de la propagande actuelle, de
l'état des médias ?
Est-ce que vous avez un point de vue
critique sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment ?
Vous savez la propagande
est un mot bon j'étais chef de la
propagande mais mon but n'était pas du
tout d'inculquer des choses la
propagande c'était quelque chose propre
au régime totalitaire ou autoritaire
qui inculque leurs idées de façon
monopoliste.
La façon de concevoir la propagande,
c'était de propager les idées humanistes
démocratiques. Aujourd'hui, si vous
voulez le mot propagande,
on ne sait plus très bien ce qu'il veut
dire, mais si s'il s'agit de vouloir à
toute force promouvoir un un message
lequel message n'est pas fondé sur des
faits, sur des choses vérifiées, mais
sur des données trompeuses ou des
messages de caractère idéologique
xénophobe raciste ou autres.
Donc je pense que la propagande est
mauvaise. Moi je je pense que
l'important
c'était l' c'est c'est l'information et
je dirais mieux que l'information c'est
la connaissance parce que les
informations euh seul
on n' pas de sens. Il faut comprendre
pourquoi on vous informe par exemple que
les deux tours, on voit que les deux
tours de Manathan ont été détruites par
des avions pirates et on se dit mais
comment il faut contextualiser il faut
comprendre à l'état brut on se dit mais
qu'est-ce que c'est alors donc on a
toujours besoin de d'une d'une
explication qui donne le contexte
historique le contexte
psychologique le contexte nécessaire
pour comprendre des événements. Donc si
vous voulez, moi je crois que il y a
deux choses importantes. La première
c'est que effectivement il faut une
pluralité de source d'information
pour que on puisse être éclairé parce
que si la seule façon de pouvoir
chercher son sa vérité la vérité à
travers une pluralité de source. Quand
vous n'avez qu'une seule source comme
c'était dans la l'Allemagne itérienne,
la Russie, dans l'URSI stalinienne, dans
la Chine Maw ou même actuellement dans
d'autres régimes, ben les gens doivent
avaler ce qu'on leur raconte et qui
n'est pas vrai. On leur occulte beaucoup
de choses et on leur raconte des choses
qui sont fausses. Il faut une pluralité,
pluralité d'opinion, pluralité de source
d'information. Ça c'est une chose
capitale. Mais une fois qu'on a cette
pluralité de source d'information, il
vous faut alors à ce moment-là un
processus de de connaissance. Comment
situer cette information dans notre
histoire, dans les événements ? D'où ça
vient, nous sert ? Parce que toujours
l'information est inséparable de la
surprise d'un événement. Plus
l'événement est est surprenant, plus
l'information est importante. Par
exemple, je vous ai cité les deux tours,
je pourrais vous citer l'explosion de
mai 68 qui n'était prévue par personne.
Ce qui est important, c'est l'événement
inattendu. Alors là, il faut essayer de
comprendre d'où il vient et quelles vont
être ces conséquences.
Même si on fait des hypothèses, il faut
il faut pouvoir faut pouvoir les faire.
Alors ça c'est un travail des
journalistes, des essayistes, des euh
[gémissement]
des historiens. Mais moi, c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire dans mes
collaborations à la presse. Par exemple,
quand il y a eu mes 68, moi j'étais la
presse n'avait aucune antenu. Étudiant,
comprenez rien. Moi, il se trouvait que
j'avais des jeunes étudiants,
collaborateurs et cetera qui étaient
dans le mouvement et que à partir de
toutes mes sources d'information et que
de ma présence dans ces événements, j'ai
pu faire dans le monde des articles
essayant d'éclairer le l'événement.
C'est ça le problème. Il faut éclairer
les événements.
Vous avez un regard critique sur la
presse du 21e siècle.
La presse ? un regard critique sur la
presse du 21e siècle, l'état du
journalisme au 21e siècle. Oui, parce
que je pense si vous voulez que il y a
pratiquement plus de presse totalement
indépendante
que la plupart des organes enfin que les
organes quotidiens et hebdomadaires les
plus connus sont dans les mains de
puissance financière
qui parfois laisse une relative liberté
au rédacteur mais avec quand même un
certain nombre d'impératifs de tabous
voire d'obligation.
Donc si vous voulez euh c'est vrai qu'on
a une presse plurielle que le Parisien
le Figaro, c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose que le monde que la libération
mais c'est vrai aussi que la presse
totalement indépendante et rare. Bon,
vous avez le cas de Mediapart qui est
une presse pas écrite mais qui est
disons de type informatique à travers
internet. Euh [grognement] vous pouvez
avoir des petites publications
minoritaires,
il y a encore possibilité de s'exprimer.
Alors, il y a ça et il y a aussi le
culte du sensationnel. Et c'est vrai que
bon, les grands événements sont
sensationnels, mais le besoin de
sensationnel fait qu'on va
sensationnaliser
des événements minuscules et surtout on
va sensationnaliser
des problèmes de vie privée, parfois
soit indiscret, soit des liaisons d'un
président de la République, soit
superficiel et suprapatoire. Moi, je
vois le nombre de de dans mon
ordinateur, dans mon de mail euh de
différents organes qui vous parlent de
petites histoires de Brigitte Marcron
absolument insignifiante. Je veux dire
que il y a aussi une une ce que disait
très justement le philosophe castoriadis
décédé malheureusement, il y a la montée
de l'insignifiance.
Euh a cette insignifiance se se traduit
effectivement par des gros titres, sur
des petits riens euh sur tel
présentateur de télévision euh qui se
fâche avec son invité viceversa euh sur
ce qu'a dit monsieur Éric Zbourg, sur ce
qu'a dit, tu vois, on est on est dans un
on est dans le le secondaire,
l'insignifiant,
les les petites phrases grottesqu que
dans l'écume des choses,
hein.
Dans l'écume des choses,
dans l'écume des choses. Oui.
Dans l'an zéro, vous vous parlez du
somnambulisme
en proie à la fin et aux rumeurs pour
décrire les Allemands.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par ça ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez faire un
parallèle avec, si je peux me permettre
de dire la population à l'heure
actuelle, est-ce que notre population
est dans un état de somnambulisme en
proie à la fin et aux rumeurs aux fake
news ?
Alors euh c'est une question très
pertinente et avant d'y répondre, je
vous parlerai de mon expérience des
années 30 à 40 qui correspondent à mon
adolescence et qui ont vu quoi ? Elles
ont vu d'abord la crise économique
mondiale. Elles ont vu la crise de la
démocratie en France avec des meus du 6
février 34. Elles ont vu l'arrivée de
Hitler au pouvoir. Elles ont vu
l'annexion de l'Autriche par
l'Allemagne. Elles ont vu la guerre
d'Espagne où l'Aspagne et l'Italie sont
intervenues pour la victoire de Franco.
Elles ont vu les accords de Munique qui
ont fait que finalement Staline a fait
le pacte germanoviétique. On a vu le
pacte germanoviétique, on a vu la
guerre.
Mais la montée vers cette chose-là se
fait dans un état de somnambulisme.
Quelques esprits disait "Oui, attention,
c'est dangereux, on va faire la guerre."
[grognement] Mais la plupart des gens ne
se ne sentaient pas ou vivent au jour le
jour où ne voulait pas voir les choses
et on est on est entré dans et même si
vous voulez la la déclaration de guerre
a été fait dans un état de
somnambulisme. Pourquoi ? On déclare la
guerre à l'Allemagne nazi parce qu'elle
a envahi la Pologne. Très bien. Mais
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait pour aider les
Polonais ? Rien. On n' pas bougé. On
déclare la guerre pour ne pas la faire
et pour pendant un an attendre. C'est ce
qu'on appelait un rôle de guerre.
attendre l'invasion qui elle-même et
surprendre l'étatmajor incapable
lui-même somnambule incapable de
recomprendre ce qui se passe. Donc
[grognement] il y a eu moi j'ai vécu
cette époque-là et je pense que dans des
conditions différentes, nous vivons une
époque de somnambulisme. On vit au jour
le jour parce que si on essaie de
regarder vers le futur, on est angoissé,
on ne sait pas ce qui va arriver. Mais
aussi les politiques, elles ont elles
ont perdu le sens de la prospective, le
sens d'une voie vers l'avenir. On
cherche simplement euh un peu plus de
croissance. Il y a la croissance, un peu
plus de PIB, un budget plus équilibré.
La la politique c'est c'est c'est
réduite à une économie. Une économie
elle même au jour le jour. On va
supprimer des postes pour le budget. Ah,
on va augmenter ailleurs. On est
toujours dans on n' pas de pensée qui
voit qui essaie de voir où l'on va qui
essaie de voir les périls. Parce que
pourquoi somnambulisme ? Parce que
pendant ce temps-là, c'est pas seulement
le réchauffement climatique, c'est toute
la dégradation des sols par
l'agriculture industrielle dans le monde
entier et pas seulement en France. C'est
euh la disparition de la biodiversité.
[grognement]
C'est euh la déforestation généralisée,
c'est euh des phénomènes, les pollution
énormes des ville et tout ce et tous ces
phénomènes centre déterminent les uns
les autres avec en plus le réchauffement
climatique pour arriver à une situation
aggravante qui elle-même va créer de
multiples problèmes humains, des
migrations, des famines euh lesquelles
vont elles-mêmes sont déjà commencé
là où règne l'agriculture industrialisée
en Afrique et où les malheureux paysans
sont obligés d'émigrer dans les
conditions que vous savez. Donc il y a
un futur inquiétant. L'arme nucléaire se
multiplie, elle se propage, elle sait
pas qu'elle s'est arrêtée
et puis elle va se miniaturiser
la l'économie mondiale, les économistes
vous disent que on est à la mercie d'une
nouvelle crise et cetera. On ne sait
pas. En tout cas, cette économie-là
produit beaucoup d'inégalités et par là
est productrice de futur désordre. Euh
euh donc si vous voulez, on est dans un
emporté dans un processus euh très
difficile à comprendre parce qu'on ne
sait pas vers où il se dirige mais en
tout cas vers des des périls certains et
donc on vit au jour le jour et donc
c'est vrai nous et c'est du reste ce que
je de temps en temps j'essaie de de
d'annoncer mais ça ne sert à rien. On ne
réveille pas, on ne peut pas éveiller,
on ne sait pas quand est-ce qu'on et
c'est toujours au dernier moment qu'on
est d'ailleurs on a nous on a été on
s'est on s'est réveillé brusquement
quand il y a eu la ruée des troupes
allemandes en France et que des millions
d'entre nous on fuit dans les routes
hein. Mais aujourd'hui ça va pas être la
même chose. C'est pas une puissance
hégémonique comme l'Allemagne qui nous
menace. C'est pas le mais la menace elle
est elle est beaucoup plus diffuse,
beaucoup plus mélangée mais on voit que
tout ça va s'entre dééterminé. Il y a
vous avez quand même aussi une nouvelle
force internationale qui est le
jihadisme qui certes c'est une minorité
une petite minorité dans le monde
musulman, mais elle est partout euh et
et elle elle est totalement fanatique.
Alors bien entendu, on dit euh on croit
que c'est nouveau, non ? Il y a eu des
millions de morts provoqués par le
goulag en urs. Il y a eu des millions de
morts provoqués au juit sur le vent. Et
maintenant ces gens-là commencent à
massacrer. Bon mais disons, on est dans
on n'est pas sorti d'une barbarie. Et
moi je dis que aujourd'hui euh nous ça
croit disons la force et la coalition de
deux deux barbaries. La première
barbarie, nous la connaissons, elle
s'était déchaînée pendant la deuxème
guerre mondiale et avec vraiment le le
nazisme et c'est
et cette barbarie là, elle revient sous
de nouvelles formes.
Est-ce que Est-ce que le capitalisme est
une barbarie ? Alors euh, on peut dire
que ce qui est barbare, c'est le
caractère incontrôlé et illimité du
profit et aujourd'hui de la finance qui
contrôle un peu tous les secteurs. Le
capitalisme n'est pas une barbarie tant
qu'elle est contrôlée par exemple tant
qu'il y a eu l'état providence, tant
qu'il y a eu des les pouvoirs des
syndicats, tant que ce pouvoir
économique a été contrebalancé,
il était pas barbare, il faisait partie
de l'économie, il avait ses ses côtés
très négatifs et ses côtés positifs. Là
aujourd'hui, il y a plus aucun contrôle.
il y a il il se il se déchaîne. Donc on
peut le considérer que c'est cette forme
nouvelle fondée uniquement sur le profit
et le profit financier. Et moi je dis
que donc la barbarie c'est évidemment la
haine, c'est le massacre, c'est le
mépris, c'est la torture, c'est toutes
ces choses qui reviennent aujourd'hui
ici là hein. D'ailleurs, vous savez,
elle a fonctionné pendant la guerre
d'Algérie et on nous le remet en mémoire
fort heureusement maintenant. Il y a
cette barbarie mais l'autre barbarie
elle est vient du cœur de notre
civilisation c'estàd où domine le calcul
le profit et on voit tout par des
chiffres et des chiffres qui empêchent
de voir les problèmes humains qui sont
parce que par le calcul vous ne
connaissez ni la souffrance ni le
bonheur ni la tristesse, ni la joie et
c'est le calcul que tous nos nos
dirigeants, nos technocrates, nos
éconocrates, ils nous connaissent par le
calcul. On est des objets de calcul et à
mon avis ces deux barbaries sont
alliées. Déjà ça avait commencé avec
Hitler parce qu'à la barbarie des camps
d'extermination c'était allié une
barbarie industrielle où on récupérait
les cheveux, les dents, les déchets des
des victimes pour en faire des pour de
nouveaux produits industriels. Donc si
vous voulez, ce sont ces deux barbaries
qui nous menacent et dans le et devant
lesquels nous sommes à peu près
somnambule. Alors là, vous avez par
exemple devant après la démission de de
Nicolas Hullot euh on on une partie de
l'opinion commence à dire "Mais tiens,
c'est a il y a beaucoup de lobby
financiers qui contrôlent les ministères
qui empêchent telle politique mais après
on on oublie on oublie on vit au jour le
jour on retombe dans le somnambulisme
hein." Et vous savez hier Héraclit le
vieux philosophe du 6e siècle avant
Jésus-Christ il a une formule
merveilleuse. Il dit éveillé, ils
dorment. Et ben nous dormons éveillés.
Est-ce que vous avez une piste pour
créer un électrochoc auprès de ces
somnambules ?
Non, je ne peux pas créer un électrochoc
et je pense que il des certains arrivent
disons un petit électrochoc comme la
démission de Nicolas Hullot. Euh des
choses comme ça peuvent peuvent arriver.
Non, moi ce que j'ai une façon de penser
qui peut nous orienter
[raclement de gorge] vers une autre
voix. C'est ça
la méthode
hein.
La méthode.
La méthode. J'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle la voix et dans la voix
j'essaie de penser à ma façon des choses
que les gens pensent en terme
contradictoire. Par exemple, je dis je
prends le thème de la croissance et je
prends celui de la décroissance. Bon,
moi je pense que les c'est je pense
qu'il faut savoir ce qui doit croître
une économie plus solidaire et ce qui
doit décroître c'est une économie de la
futilité, une économie de de
consommation nocive. Il y a beaucoup de
choses. On voit il faut il faut l'avoir
faire croître une économie utile et
faire décroître une économie nocible.
Bon, comme le développement
bien sûr, il faut développement
technique économique, mais si vous
détruisez les solidarités traditionnelle
des civilisations, vous faites une
nouvelle barbarie. Donc, il faut
développer et envelopper. [grognement]
Et j'ajourai, il faut le mondialisation,
qu'est-ce qu'elle a de positif ? et
qu'elle permet une mondialisation
culturelle
importante. Moi, je suis très heureux
d'avoir vu hier le film Burning, le film
sud-coréen qui très beau film comme j'ai
vu des films admirables qui viennent des
autres continents, [raclement de gorge]
je suis pour la mondialisation
culturelle pour des échanges mais la
mondialisation qui crée la
désertification humaine économique dans
certaines régions dans nos dans nos
régions.
Il faut mondialiser mais localiser. Plus
on mondialise, plus il faut localiser,
plus il faut sauver nos territoires.
[grognement] Donc moi, j'ai cette vue
que j'appelle complexe en fonction de la
de ma façon de penser et je pense que à
partir de ceci, on pourrait ouvrir une
nouvelle voie. Donc le vrai problème
c'est que il y ait assez de force
bouillonnante intellectuelle pratique
parce que vous savez dans notre société
comme partout il y a partout des des des
oasis de solidarité de fraternité aussi
bien à partir de de d'agroécologie
d'écoquartiers d'associations
multiples. Il y a l'économie sociale et
solidaire il y a beaucoup de
bouillonnement. Vers quoi ? vers ce que
on souhaite, ce que chacun souhaite,
c'estàdire vers un peu d'épanouissement
individuel au sein toujours d'une
communauté fraternelle et il y a ces
mouvements là qui dans mais ils sont
dispersés, il y a pas une pensée
directrice. Moi je crois que tant qu'il
y a pas une pensée directrice, on ne
pourra pas aller dans cette nouvelle
voie. Moi, j'ai essayé de formuler cette
pensée. B, j'ai eu quelques lecteurs,
mais très aucun politique sans doute est
inspiré. Mais je pense que on peut
trouver une autre voie. Voilà. Mais je
ne pense pas que et les électrochocs
ils viendront de même.
Et ben, vous savez, par exemple, la
canicule qu'il a eu cet été n'a pas été
un électrochoc. les gens pas été
contents du tout mais ils n'ont pas
compris que c'était un déjà la
prémonition de réchauffement.
Quand Nicolas Hul euh parle
d'effondrement, d'effondrement de des
espèces, d'effondrement des ressources,
vous du haut de votre grand âge,
ça vous fait penser à quoi ça ? Ça vous
fait sentir la barbarie revenir ? Ça
vous fait penser à quoi ?
L'effondrement.
L'effondrement. Le collapse.
Le collapse. Écoutez moi, je pense que
j'ai lu des livres intéressants sur la
question.
Lesquel lesquels ?
Ils sont très logiques.
Ben, c'est
l'effondrement qui vient.
C'est comment tu peux s'effondrer ?
Voilà. Bon, alors dont les deux auteurs,
j'ai pas leur nom en tête. Enfin,
Pablo Servigne, non.
Bon, enfin écoutez, j'ai lu une bonne
littérature, je pense que les processus
actuels il conduisent, c'est logique.
Mais je me mon espoir c'est que souvent
la vie échappe à la logique,
c'est-à-dire qu' survient des
initiatives créatrices qui sont pas
logiques. que c'est
disons la l'apparition si vous pensez du
passé dans le passé de de Bouddha du
prince Sakiamoun qui a transformé créé
une nouvelle religion pour au moins une
grande partie de l'Asie. C'était un
événement imprévisible qui a c'est comme
le christianisme qui était sorti un
petit truc marginal dans une petite
province de l'Empire romain invisible au
contemporain et qui en 3 siècles est
devenu une relue. Ben vous avez
l'imprévu, l'imprévisible, le créatif
surgisse dans l'histoire. Moi, j'espère
en tout ça si je peux y contribuer, tant
mieux. On fait quoi des religions au
Ouais, on en fait quoi ? On les jette,
on discute avec les jetés. Vous savez,
les religions euh sont d'abord des
religions. La religion la plus
matérialiste, la plus technique est en
même temps la plus religieuse. Ce sont
les États-Unis.
Un pays ou plutôt l'Union soviétique en
70 ans a essayé d'extirper la religion
orthodoxe, elle a rendu plus forte que
jamais. N'essayons pas d'extirper les
religions. Par contre, faisons un effort
pour que les religions reviennent à leur
source la meilleure. Alors, quelles sont
les sources
pour le christianisme ? évidence, c'est
le message de fraternité de Jésus qu'on
trouve dans les évangiles. Et c'est pas
l'inquisition,
c'est pas les croisades, hein, c'est pas
le l'antijudaïsme, c'est pas tout ça.
Non, c'est c'est les sources les sources
qui ont animé aussi qui qui ont animé
depuis Saint-François jusqu'à l'Abé
Pierre ou Mère Thesa. L'islam,
la prière islamique, elle com elle parle
d' là, le clément et le miséricordieux.
Donc vous avez aussi cet élément, ce qui
n'empêche pas que historiquement l'islam
a été une religion conquérante euh
brutale. Bien sûr, elle n'a pas commis
l'inquisition comme le christianisme,
mais elle a eu aussi sa part de
barbarie. Et aujourd'hui, il y a une
partie évidemment qui est barbare. Mais
ces religions devraient retourner à leur
à leur véritable source. Bon, quant au
bouddhisme, bon ces sources sont très
pacifiques. Ce qui s'est trouvé, c'est
que aujourd'hui dans des pays boudhiques
où il y a où inhindouiste où il y a
coexistence avec des avec de l'islam, le
choc des deux religions transforme
l'islamisme, non l'hindouisme pardon ou
le bouddhisme en entité agressive quoi.
[grognement]
Donc ça ça s'aggrave. Mais ces religions
ont toute une source. D'abord la vertu,
disons de du bouddhisme, de
christianisme, de l'islam,
c'est d'être des religions
universalistes. Elles s'adressent à tous
les êtres humains de tous les
continents, de toutes les races. Or moi
je dirais à ces religions, surtout les
monothéistes, je le dirais
la seule test qui montrera que vous ayez
progressé en retournant à vos sources,
c'est que vous vous travaillez à faire
de Jérusalem une ville désarmée, une une
ville libre et libre de vos religions.
Voilà. Mais tant qu'ils ne resteront pas
à s'entendre, je pense que les religions
mais regardez le pape François joue un
rôle très positif dans son message aussi
bien sur l'économie que sur l'écologie.
Vous pouvez voir dans ces religions des
moments absolument
disons aujourd'hui le christianisme
disons sous cette forme là est retourné
véritablement à sa source.
Est-ce que vous êtes croyant ? Est-ce
que vous avez un ami imaginaire ? Est-ce
que vous croyez dans un Dieu, dans une
foi particulière, mis à part la
fraternité ? Écoutez, je pense que les
dieux, ce sont des créations humaines.
Euh et ce qui est très remarquable,
c'est que quand une communauté humaine
croit en un dieu, ces dieux, ils
prennent une existence objective euh
pour les croyants. Ils disent, il leur
donne de de les adorer, de les supplier,
de tuer ou de mourir. C'est-à-dire que
nous créons des dieux qui existent. Et
c'est vrai pour tous les dieux de
l'antiquité, Mitra et ou Apollon ou tous
ces dieux et c'est vrai aussi pour nos
dieux actuels à mon avis.
Donc si vous voulez, je suis pas
croyant, je ne suis pas je pense qu'il y
a un mystère de l'univers que la raison
humaine est incapable de saisir. Je
pense que même du reste les sciences
nous y conduisent parce que quand les
sciences astrophysiques essayent de
s'interroger sur l'univers de sur
l'origine du monde, ben elles arrivent
devant des paradoxes. Le monde plein
d'énergie à sortie du vide, mais comment
le vide peut créer d'énergie et cetera ?
D'ailleurs, on ne sait pas, on ne
comprend pas. On disons le pourquoi
il y a un univers plutôt que rien. On le
sait pas. Il y a un grand mystère.
Comment d'où vient cette créativité qui
caractérise l'évolution biologique, qui
a créé les fleurs, qui a créé la
diversité du monde animal, qui a créé
tout ça, qui nous a créé nous. Bon, elle
est à la nature comme disait Spinoza.
Mais moi, je crois que notre monde est
étonnant, notre monde est fabuleux,
notre monde a des choses horribles et
des choses merveilleuses. Mais je ne
peux pas dire quel est son secret. Son
secret échappe à l'humanité.
Alors, qu'est-ce que il me reste à faire
? Ce qui me reste à faire, c'est de
merveiller m'émerveiller des beautés du
monde et pas seulement des beautés de la
nature qui sont innombrables,
y compris les couchés de soleil, des
beautés architecturales, des beautés des
personnes, des beautés des belles
œuvres, des beautés et pour résister
comme on peut aux horreurs du monde, à
tout ce qu'elle porte comme mort,
destruction, barbarie et cetera.
Comment on fait pour résister ? Comment
on fait la tête ?
On fait d'abord on résiste dans son
esprit. Onentre pas dans ses logiques
barbares. On on n'y consomme pas. C'est
la première résistance est une
résistance de l'esprit. Vous savez sous
l'occupation les premières résistances
ont été des résistances de l'esprit.
Après quelques individus se sont
associés pour résister mais on dit on
dit non on n'est pas on peut pas on peut
pas accepter ça. On essaie de faire
comme on peut.
Une question d'internet. Le mal est-il
nécessaire pour ensuite laisser place au
bien ?
Écoutez, je ne peux pas répondre. La
seule chose que je peux dire,
[grognement] c'est depuis que l'origine
de l'univers, ce que nous ont appris les
astrophysiciens,
c'est qu'il y a à la fois des forces
d'union, d'association qui ont créé les
atomes, les molécules, les astres, les
galaxies et des forces de désunion, de
destruction qui ont détruit l'entrée
matière qui font que les étoiles à un
moment donné meurent et éclatent, qui
fait qu'il y ait des trous loin noir et
cetera. Et quand vous prenez l'évolution
biologique, vous voyez également aussi
comme disait Héraclit que Concorde et
Discord sont père et mère de toute
chose. Vous voyez pas seulement la lune
pour la vie, la prédation, qu'on se
mange les uns les autres, vous voyez des
phénomènes de coopération innombrables,
pas seulement à l'intérieur d'une
espèce, mais entre les champignons et
les arbres, entre les les abeilles et
les fleurs et cetera. Vous avez de la
coopération et la compétition, vous avez
des forces d'union et des forces de
mort. Et quand vous voyez l'histoire
humaine au niveau humain, c'est pareil.
Vous voyez ce que j'ai appelé la
barbarie, c'est-à-dire les forces de
mort qu'on peut appeler
Thanatos, mot grec qui signifie la mort
et les forces d'union, d'amour qu'on
peut appeler héros du mot grec qui
signifie puis l'amour. Et le lien entre
Héros et Thanatos
existe début début de l'univers
existera jusqu'à la fin. Leur combat
durera jusqu'à la fin. Il est
inextricable.
Et la seule conclusion que j'en tire,
prenons le parti des ROS contre celui de
Thanatos.
Je voudrais qu'on discute de la mort.
De la mort.
De la mort. Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire ? Quel est votre rapport à
la mort ? Qu'est-ce que
Qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire ?
Vous savez, mon rapport à la mort, il
est multiple. Premièrement, parce que
ma mère a voulu m'avorter parce qu'elle
avait une maladie de cœur. Donc, j'ai
risqué la mort dès que en tant
qu'embryon. Ensuite, je suis né mort,
étouffé et le gynéco a dû me tenir par
les pieds, me gifler une demi-heure pour
que je fasse un cri. Ma mère est morte
quand j'avais 10 ans. J'étais enfant
unique. Ça a été un peut-être
l'événement le plus tragique et le plus
important de de ma vie. Euh ensuite euh
quand j'ai décidé d'entrer dans la
résistance au début de 1942,
euh j'ai couru le risque de mort en
sachant que à l'époque euh je pouvais
survivre me plaquant mais que si je
voulais vraiment vivre, il fallait que
je ma vie. Et j'ai eu aussi beaucoup de
camarades qui sont morts sous la torture
ou bien déporté. Euh donc si vous voulez
et puis j'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle l'homme et la mort parce que
justement c'est un problème qui
m'intéressait qui m'importait c'était
sur les attitudes humaines à l'égard de
la mort. Alors [grognement] moi
personnellement,
j'ai une de je suis double, c'est-à-dire
d'un côté, non seulement je pense mais
je sens que quand je participe à ces
forces d'union à la fraternité, à ce que
ce qui m'enthousiasme,
ce qui me donne de l'ardeur, je pense
que l'angoisse de mort est est refoulée
et puis j'ai des moments de vide où
brusquement je me dis mais c'est c'est
moi, c'est pas seulement corps, mais
c'est mon moi, mon jeu qui vont
s'anéantir. C'est le monde qui va
s'anentir. à ce moment-là, j'ai un
sentiment de vide et puis après je rep
je ça disparaît et je reviens à cette
idée que il n'y a que en si vous voulez
dans la communion et dans l'amour que
l'on trouve la réposte à la mort. Je dis
vous savez le cantique des cantiques dit
fort comme la que l'amour est fort comme
la mort. Il [grognement] n'est peut-être
pas aussi fort mais il est très fort et
peut la refouler.
Revenons à des choses plus terre à
terre. Emmanuel Macron.
Oui.
Pour vous, c'est un bon président, un
mauvais président, les qu'est-ce qu'il a
amélioré ? Qu'est-ce qui fait peur de
choses ? Qu'est-ce qu'il a comme point
positif ?
Vous savez, moi je c'est trop tôt pour
que je lui mette une épistète de bon ou
de mauvais président.
C'est une personnalité tout d'abord qui
m'a frappé par
son énergie,
sa culture et et mais je dirais même sa
stratégie. Euh
bon, il m'a j'ai aussi été sensible au
fait que
c'est un être qui a transgressé les
coutumes bourgeoises provinciales en
épousant une femme plus âgée qui était
son professeur. Bon al ce sont toute une
série de traits personnels mais il y a
deux choses qui me mettent sur la
réserve. La première c'est sur le plan
personnel.
Il y a un peu trop de paroles lancées
comme ça spontanément
euh qui témoigne d'une méconnaissance
des réalités vécues et je dirais même de
du mépris pour ceux qui ne réussissent
pas. Alors que moi, j'aime beaucoup les
gens qui ne réussissent pas parce que la
réussite économique pour moi n'est pas
un signe de grandeur mais parfois c'est
un signe qu'on a pu employer des
procédés pas très beaux pour aboutir
pour réussir. Enfin parce que des
paroles comme
il n'y a qu'à traverser la rue pour
trouver du travail, des paroles comme il
y a des gens qui ne sont rien, des
paroles comme je souhaite que les
français soient millionnaires, soit
rêvent d'être millionnaire. Touses ces
paroles montrent qu'il est dans dans un
autre univers et je pense aussi que euh
son expérience économique
fait que il est persuadé de la
légitimité
de ce libéralisme économique qui
consiste à favoriser les entre
l'entreprise, c'est-à-dire finalement
les possédants en entreprise
et qui en fait utilise
ces subventions pas nécessairement pour
l'investissement mais pour la
répartition des bénéfices en action.
Je pense qu'il est dans un univers
économique et que euh qu'il essaie de
d'améliorer par des mesures budgétaires
comme des coupures de postes de
fonctionnaires ou autres des économies
et qu'il est dans ce qui est l'économie
le plus classique. Bien entendu, il
essaie sur le plan international de
relancer l'Europe, de faire des choses,
mais je [grognement] pense que
alors quel est mon espoir ? Mon espoir,
c'est que quelqu'un qui veut laisser sa
marque dans l'histoire, s'il continue
dans le sens actuel, il ne laissera pas
une marque grande parce que il continue
à poli. On ne peut laisser sa marque
dans l'histoire que si on suit une
nouvelle voix. Et c'est un peu, disons
un peu comme après la crise de 29 ce
qu'a fait le président Rooswell qui a
fait un New Deal. Aujourd'hui, je pense
qu' New Deal possible français mais soit
à la base d'abord des énergies propres,
une politique massive pour des énergies
propres, une politique de dépollution
des villes qui à ce moment-là donnera du
travail, des parkings, de la
piétonisation et cetera, de dépollution
des campagnes avec des pollution de
l'alimentation et la consommation.
Enfin, il y a une grande politique
possible euh qui donerait en même temps
un exemple pour l'Europe et pour le
monde. [grognement] Et je pense que
c'est euh j'espère qu'un jour il pourra
s'orienter là-dessus. Voilà. Mais euh
pour le moment, je suis sur
l'expectative.
Euh je ne veux pas faire je je ne suis
pas un panfletire donc je ne tiens pas
des propos antimacron. Euh j'ai fait une
fois un article dans le monde où je
parlais du double jeu de Macron J, pas
Juu, où je où où j'essayais de me de me
persuader que vu qu'il est capable de
transgresser les règles, y compris quand
il s'est lancé à la course de la
présidence, il est peut-être capable
encore de transgresser mais avec
incertitude.
Donc voilà, je je pense que la démission
de Hulo est un signe pour moi plus
inquiétant que positif parce qu'il
montre que ce gouvernement reste dans la
logique des lobby financiers et que
finalement tout ça c'est de c'est le
monde ancien, c'est l'immobilisme, c'est
pas le nouveau monde.
Je voudrais qu'on parle de d'Edouard
Snowden.
Des
Edouard Snowden. Snowden. Ah oui
[grognement] bah les
lanceurange
les lanceurs d'alerte sont utiles parce
que si vous voulez finalement internet
devient révèle tout son ambivalence d'un
côté c'est un moyen de contrôle
incroyable des pouvoirs sur nous et d'un
autre côté il suffit quelqu'un un
mathématicien très doué [grognement]
capable de déchiffrer des
des codes secrets et capable capable de
lancer des alertes, d'informer
l'opinion mondiale sur des secrets
d'état qui sont nécessaires à notre
connaissance de citoyen. Donc je pense
que je suis Snowen est tout à fait
louable.
Pourquoi on leur donne pas l'asile
hein ?
l'asile politique ?
si ça tenait qu'à moi. Mais là aussi, je
pense que
il y a beaucoup de de cas où la France
manque à sa tradition d'hospitalité et
pas seulement pour Snowen et aussi dans
d'autres cas de migrants et de réfugiés.
Est-ce que vous avez des pistes pour
résoudre le conflit israélo-palestinien
?
Écoutez, au point où nous en sommes, la
situation est totalement bloquée. Mais
sinon, les solutions
étaient connues. Les solutions c'était
quoi ? C'était deux États coexistants
avec une double capitale à Jérusalem,
un statut pour les réfugiés.
Et euh c'était ça. Mais cette solution
est devenue quasi impossible avec la
colonisation massive de la SJordanie,
avec la coupure entre Gaza et la
SJordanie et avec la décomposition
de l'autorité palestinienne
euh
c'est-à-dire qui qui pourrait renaître
si Bargouzi qui lequel est en prison été
délibéré par Israël. Donc actuellement
pas, il est évident que s'il y avait la
possibilité d'une conférence
internationale sur l'ensemble des
problèmes du Moyen-Orient qui pourrait
inclure la question
israélo-palestinienne en même temps que
Syrie, Irak, hein, euh ce serait une
chose utile mais pour le moment nous
n'en ve pas les les possibilités.
Donc si vous voulez, moi mon attitude
c'est que je n'oublie pas euh un peuple
malheureux euh [gémissement]
un peuple qu'on tente à oublier les
Palestiniens et mais je ne vois plus
aujourd'hui
de de piste. Voilà. Mais je sais que
l'histoire est changeante, on peut
trouver des conditions nouvelles. Euh il
y avait déjà cette proposition ancienne
de l'Arabie Saoudite qui correspond à ce
que je vous ai dit et que
mais actuellement les alliances que
conclu Nathanahou
un peu partout et notamment avec des
régimes européens comme Hongrie et
cetera montre que le pouvoir de droite
israélien se fortifie sur le plan
international et sur le plan local. Et
actuellement, je ne vois pas de d'issu.
Est-ce que vous connaissez Krishna Murti
?
Ah oui, je l'ai lu. Oui. Oui. Et ben
c'est un c'est un sage. C'est un c'est
un Oui, bien sûr.
Qu'est-ce que vous gardez de de son
enseignement ?
Euh, écoutez, je garde une une tentative
d'arriver
à une vision du monde plus sereine, plus
ouverte, plus cosmique.
Je je pense et vous savez je il y a
Krishna Murti mais il y a il y avait
auparavant
euh votre génération les connaît pas
c'était Romain Roland qui avait écrit
des livres sur la la vie de Rama Krista
la vie de Vivan Nanda,
de Robindo, c'est-à-dire c'était des des
sages syncrétistes hindoux qui en
quelque sorte prenaient le meilleur de
la culture occidentale et le meilleur de
cette culture hindouiste comme Christin
Murtier. Et dans le fond, moi je je
pense que c'est très bon parce que nous
devons prendre beaucoup aussi de de
l'Orient. Euh là aussi, c'est comme dans
l'Occident, il y a des choses un
humanisme merveilleux surtout quand il
est sensible à la souffrance comme
l'humanisme de Tolstoy ou de Dostoyki.
Et vous avez aussi une vous avez quelque
chose aussi d'un sentiment humaniste et
cosmique beaucoup plus large en Orient.
Et vous avez en Chine la tradition
double tradition Tao et Confuséenne qui
sont des traditions très riches et tout
ce qui peut un peu mettre ensemble
c'estes c'est cette ses pensées et ses
sagesses est bon et ça va dans le sens
d'un universalisme enrichi
en ce moment en ce moment on parle
beaucoup de la montée des populismes.
Est-ce que vous avez un regard critique
sur ce qui est décrit comme la montée
des populismes ?
Écoutez, je passe mon temps à penser que
l'utilisage du mot populiste, qui est un
mot très sympathique pour stigmatiser
des politiques antipathiques, ça n'a pas
de sens. d'autant moins de sens que le
populisme a existé en Amérique du Sud
comme mouvement d'émancipation des
peuples qui étaient soumis à la
féodalité aristocratique terrienne et
militaire. Les populistes, il y a eu la
PRA au Pérou, il y a eu dans des donc le
mot populiste
n'est pas adéquat. On n' pas trouvé le
mot qui convient. Alors moi, j'emploie
le mot des systèmes néoautoritaires,
des systèmes néoautoritaires
semi-post démocratique. Enfin, il y a
peut-être pas de mot. Alors, c'est
certain que nous vivons une époque
mondiale régressive. Dans cette époque
mondiale régressive, nous voyons non
seulement la décomposition
euh et la crise des démocraties
qui sont en plus vides tout connu, mais
de plus en plus l'idée qu'il faut
trouver dans un chef charismatique
le guide et la solution. Moi je vois
même en Italie, c'est pas seulement ce
qui se passe avec ces nouvelles
élections. Beaucoup d'Italien que j'ai
connu qui eux sont d'une génération qui
n'ont ils n'ont pas connu Mussolini. Ah
si on avait Mussolini un dou un chef le
rêve. Autrement dit, on est dans une
époque régressive à l'échelle mondiale
et à l'échelle européenne puisque le
phénomène, disons la Turquie qui est un
pays aussi européen est un pays
néoautoritaire.
La Russie est un pays qui aussi né
autoritaire. La Hongrie, la Pologne,
l'Autriche,
la France. La France.
La France avec Jupiter,
hein.
La France avec Jupiter.
Là, écoutez, c'est vrai que c'est pas la
même chose parce que la
c'est de l'autorité douce.
C'est pas le régime fondé sur les
restrictions de la démocratie et fondé
sur une idéologie
xénophobe
un peu raciste
qui est beaucoup plus le fait du Front
National ou de certaines forces de
droite. Peut-être que la France peut
aller vers enfin ou que Macron dans des
conditions développe point de vue
autoritaire, mais on ne peut pas
assimiler ce type ce qui se passe au
contraire, on peut dire que en France
notamment après le dialogue prélectoral
entre Macron et Marine Le Pen, euh
Macron a pu stopper la montée
qui est alors irrésistible du Front
National
indirectement provoquer une crise
interne avec des Isadanis que nous
connaissons et stopper là. Donc Macron
donne un surcis de quelques années, mais
si ces années sont des années stériles,
on retrouvera le problème.
Et les gens réclameront un Kaiser, les
gens les gens réclameront un leader
charismatique pour s'extraire de des
problèmes de la crise, des problèmes
climatiques ou des choses comme ça.
J'ai pas bien compris. Est-ce que les
gens par le populisme ou ce qui est
appelé le populisme vont réclamer un
Kaiser, un leader charismatique comme
Erdogan, Poutine, Kim Jungun, Donald
Trump ? Bah écoute, peut-être parce que
il est certain que l'on voit que
certains démagogues de type autoritaire
comme Trompe et cetera réussissent. Euh
peut-être que Marine Le Pen a raté le
coche. Euh peut-être que Macron se
transformera en chef autoritaire, ce qui
n'est pas. Mais je crois que pour le
moment euh la France
est encore n'est pas n'est pas encore
dans dans cette logique mais qui la
menace.
[grognement]
Mais vous savez, on traverse des époques
régressives. Dans ces cas-là, il faut
des oasis de résistance et puis après
arrivent des conjonctures meilleures
peut-être pour d'autres générations
parce que finalement les régimes
autoritaires, ils ont leur faiblesse ils
s'écroulent.
C'est pas seulement il s'écroulent pas
seulement parce qu'ils sont des défaites
militaires comme le nazisme, ils
s'écroulent tout seul comme l'Union
soviétique s'est écroulé tout seul.
L'Union soviétique s'est pas écroulé
toute seule hein. L'Union soviétique
s'est pas écroulé toute seule.
Oui.
La course à l'armement il a fait pour
beaucoup.
Ah écoutez, elle s'est décroulé toute
seule. Pourquoi ? Parce que un elle a
fait la guerre en Afghanistan.
de elle s'est lancée dans la course aux
armements avec les États-Unis
mais trois parce que elle a connu un
réformateur humaniste qui était
Gorbatchov et que Gorbachov a raté sa
réforme. C'estàd il il a il n'a pas
réussi à réformer l'économie. Au
contraire, il a aggravé la situation. Il
a réussi à apporter la glacelote,
c'est-à-dire un peu de liberté. Euh, il
a réussi encore bah dans finalement à
détruire le pouvoir monopoliste du parti
dont il était secrétaire général. Bon,
il a conduit euh son alors après la
suite a conduit non pas euh à ce qu'on
peut appeler le marché économique mais
le dom la domination des mafias. euh un
chaos économique épouvantable dont il
sort à peine, mais je peux dire que
l'Union soviétique c'est on ne l'a pas
effondré de l'extérieur. Le nazisme, on
l'a tué de l'extérieur. L'empire
austro-hongrois, il a été démoli par le
traité de Versailles. L'Empire ottoman a
été démoli par le traité de Versailles.
Tout ça c'est que donc c'est assez
intéressant de penser que voilà.
Est-ce que vous avez un car critique sur
l'anarchie ?
L'anarchie ? Et ben écoutez pour moi si
je regarde ce qu'était la
disons les les aspirations profondes de
rénovation à la fin du 19e siècle était
associé entre elles le libertarisme
c'estàd l'anarchisme avec
Bakunin Kropotkin qui était pour
l'épanouissement de l'individu. Il y
avait le socialisme qui était pour
l'amélioration de la société. Il y avait
le communisme qui était pour la
communauté fraternelle de tous et il y
avait pas encore l'écologie qui n' plus
tard. Mais ces courants étaient liés.
Par exemple pour Carl Marx, la dictature
du prolétariat était professore pour
aboutir à la société sans état et sans
classe. Et d'ailleurs, c'est ce que
Linin écrivait peu avant la révolution
de 17 dans son livre L'État et la
révolution. Donc le communisme marxisme
avait pour finalité l'anarchie. C'était
pas entièrement opposé mais tous ces
mouvements se sont opposés et opposés
avec violence. Les communistes ont
détruit les socialistes et quand il y a
eu des tentatives communistes après la
guerre de de 18, les socialistes ont
détruit les la révolution communiste.
Donc mais moi mon idée c'est que il faut
relier ces aspirations et qu'il faut
respecter l'aspiration libertaire qu'il
faut l'intégrer. Et d'ailleurs, je pense
que en France
cette tradition était assez occulté par
la tradition marxiste et cetera, mais
moi, j'ai connu des merveilleuses
personnalités,
anarchiste comme M. Picré euh qui était
une une femme libertaire et qui du reste
pour montrer que son euh
son écuménisme, elle [grognement] a elle
a voulu avoir un enfant noir, un enfant
peau rouge et un enfant juif.
C'est-à-dire euh mais j'ai il y a pas
mal de j'ai j'ai fréquenté euh des
libertaires et euh aujourd'hui encore il
y a ce centre libertaire rue des
Vignoles euh
surtout qui maintient la mémoire des
libertaires espagnols parce que moi mon
premier acte politique quand j'avais 15
ans, c'était la guerre d'Espagne.
Je suis allé à Solidarité Internationale
antifasciste qui est un organisme
libertaire pour des colis au à la
colonne du Routi qui était la colonne
libertaire et aux anarchistes de
Catalogne. Moi, avant de pouvoir d'être
pendant la guerre communiste, j'ai
sympathisé avec tous ces mouvements qui
ont été exterminés en Espagne, pas
seulement par Franco, mais aussi par les
communistes, les Républicains, le pou
qui était un mouvement gauchiste et les
libertaires. [grognement] Donc, si vous
voulez, moi je euh je respecte beaucoup
les
libertaires et d'enfant en France, nous
avons eu quand même Brassin est un bel
exemple de libertarisme. [grognement]
Michel Lf enfin qui est un type un peu
excessif mais enfin quand même moi je
moi je crois que il faut reconnaître
l'intérêt de la pensée libertaire en
France.
Vous avez un avis sur Michel Onfay
hein ?
Vous avez un avis sur Michel Onf ?
Il exagère. Ah ouais, on confirme. Il
exagère. Mais enfin, il a fait des
choses positives comme son université
populaire à quand mais je pense que dans
ces polémiques, que ce soit contre
Freud, contre Alain, contre tout ça, il
se déchaîne, il il exagère. Mais sinon,
c'est un esprit laïque, intéressant,
libertaire. Mais voilà,
on lui a raccroché au nez hier,
hein.
On lui a raccroché au nez hier.
On lui a raccroché au nez.
On lui a raccroché au nez. Qui ?
Nous.
Ah oui
ouais ouais. Bon c'est un détail. Euh
est-ce que vous avez un modèle
alternatif au capitalisme ? C'est une
question internet. Je vais la répéter un
peu plus fort puis je vais me
rapprocher. Quel modèle alternatif au
capitalisme ?
Alors il y a pas de modèle. Ce qu'il y a
c'est que il faut il y a une voix une
voix qui consiste à refouler
progressivement parce qu'on ne peut pas
rien faire. On ne peut pas faire aucune
révolution et même si vous faites de
l'impôt sur le les grosses fortunes,
elle s'évate toutes à l'étranger. Donc
c'est pas ça. Vous ne pouvez pas rien
faire, vous pouvez pas le supprimer.
Rien, vous pouvez refouler. Si dans les
campagnes vous favorisez l'agriculture,
l'agroécologie, l'agriculture fermière,
l'agriculture raisonné, vous repoussez
le pouvoir de ces énormes forces
économiques.
Bon, si dans l'aliment, si dans la
consommation vous changez les habitudes,
ne serait-ce que en vous nourrissant du
local, en évitant de prendre les
produits
en hiver qui viennent de l'été du
continent
de l'hémisphère austral
en en éliminant ces ces produits sucré
euh [grognement] qui donne l'obéité aux
jeunes
en en en évitant les produits futiles
qui donnent soi-disant la beauté et
cetera en évite en en choisissant les
les les produits qui n'ont qui sont qui
n'ont pas d'obsolescence programmée pour
se détruire au bout de 10 ans et en
favorisant les produits durables et leur
réparation, on peut progressivement
refouler les puissances dominantes de
l'argent et progressivement créer et un
mieux vivre qui s'étendra. Voilà les
choses possibles. Mais tout dépend de la
conjoncture mondiale, tout dépend de
reste mais ça c'est possible.
On arrive à la fin bientôt de notre
interview. J'ai de deux petites
questions, trois petites questions
encore. Qu'est-ce qui tient votre compte
Twitter ? C'est vous ? Bien sûr, vous me
prenez plus pour qui.
Bah moi je moi ça m'indigne quand on
pense que j'utilise des pour
faire mon compte. J'ai tout ce que j'ai
écrit, je l'écrit personnellement. Je
n'ai jamais utilisé de et quand
j'ai eu des collaborateurs, j'ai donné
leur nom. Alors mon compte est
intégralement de moi.
C'est un compte Twitter de quelqu'un qui
a 25 ans. Non
de d'un gamin de 25 ans.
Ouais.
Écoutez, il y a de tout mais il y a des
quand je il y a des choses qui m'amusent
et des choses très sérieuse que je dis
euh vous savez ce qu'il y a ce qui me
plaît c'est d'abord de pouvoir un peu
espérer s'aimer des pensées qui me
viennent et que je trouve soit
intéressantes, soit utile, soit
amusante. D'ailleurs, je parfois je je
glisse des idées qui correspondent à la
pensée complexe qui m'anime, mes à mes
propres pensées. Bon, parfois je cite
des auteurs qui me qui me plaisent pour
que donner du plaisir
à à ceux qui suivent mes compes Twitter.
Et parfois vous partagez des petits
chats,
hein.
Parfois vous partagez des petits chats.
Oui, oui, mais oui, parce que j'adore
les chats.
Bienvenue sur internet. Mais oui, mais
écoutez Mais oui, mais écoutez parce que
moi je suis quelqu'un qui j'ai toutes
les dimensions de l'existence. Euh,
j'aime les chats, j'aime les chiens,
j'aime la
bonne nourriture. Il y a des choses, je
suis un être humain normal. Non, ce
qu'il y a aussi dans les tweets, c'est
que il vous oblige à faire ce que
faisait la roche fouo ou Jubert,
c'est-à-dire de faire des maximes assez
denses et donc de d'être obligé de
d'avoir une une expression à la fois
forte et courte. C'est une sorte de
challenge de de jeu qui parfois me me
plaît. Et pire le fait que sans le
vouloir et j'ai maintenant euh 109000
followers euh fait que maintenant et je
me sens de même qu' qu'on est obligé de
donner la béquée aux petits oiseaux là
qui viennent vous trouver.
Je me suis obligé de donner la béquée
et c'est-à-dire de dire mais ce qui me
sort par la tête que ce qui m'intéresse,
ce qui m'arrivé. Voilà.
Et vous en prenez beaucoup quand même de
vos 100000 109000 followers hein.
On voit que vous partagez beaucoup de
des publications qui ne sont pas de
vous. C'estàd vous imprégnez de
l'internet. Beaucoup. Oui, mais je Oui,
parce que je fais des lectures et
parfois je tombe sur un auteur qui dit
une phrase qui m'intéresse. Je suis
tombé l'autre fois sur une phrase de
Lichtenberg,
ce cet écrivain allemand de la fin du
[raclement de gorge] 18e siècle qui m'a
plu. Je je l'ai mise. Voilà.
[grognement] Euh bah c'est je je veux
faire partager des choses qui
m'intéressent.
Une question un peu plus personnelle,
vous êtes pas obligé d'y répondre. Je
voudrais savoir la symbolique de vos
bagues
de ma symbolique
de vos bagues ? Est-ce que vos bagues
ont une symbolique particulière ?
Ah
bah écoutez,
bah oui, parce que il y en a une, ben
c'est une bague que j'avais trouvé dans
un musée. C'est un copié sur le modèle
égyptien et on voit à Montr le dieu
égyptien le du soleil. cette bague m'a
plu et je l'ai acheté, je la garde.
L'autre c'est ça, c'était une c'était
mon père euh qui quand je suis né
m'avait offert une un petit collier en
or et quand j'ai grandi, il a transformé
le collier en bague. Et j'ai cette bague
depuis mon enfance, je la garde, elle
arrive même plus à sortir.
Là c'est mon alliance et là et ben c'est
une bague
où il y a les syllabes sacrés
bouddhistes ou hindouistes. Voilà. Donc
c'est un peu
la mystique orientale qui se trouve là.
[grognement] Là c'est la religion
égyptienne parce qu'elle était très
belle. Et puis voilà. Alors pourquoi
est-ce que j'aime les bagues ? J'en suis
rien.
On pose toujours la même question à nous
inviter. C'est laisser un C'est
d'ailleurs pas une question, c'est
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
[raclement de gorge]
Bien. Tout à l'heure je je vous ai dit
que
bon le monde était livré à une sorte de
combat entre Hos et Tanatos.
et je dirais que bien entendu euh plus
ils prennent le parti de tout ce qui est
fraternel, de tout ce qui est amour,
plus il seront bien même à travers les
périls. Mais la chose que je leur dirai
aussi, c'est que certainement ils vivent
une situation de précarité, souvent
d'incertitude contre à leur avenir.
Mais je le dirai c'est vrai. Mais moi
aussi j'ai une je suis pas d'une
génération qui a vécu beaucoup
d'incertitude avec en plus la guerre et
l'occupation. Et dans le fond on est
dans une aventure humaine qui a toujours
été tourmentée et dans lequel on est
inséré qu'on le veuille ou non.
Alors, je dire sachez que vous êtes un
moment dans cette aventure que vous y
participer. Essayez d'y participer de la
meilleure façon. Et [grognement] je leur
dirai aussi, qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une
vie ? Une vie bonne, c'est une vie où
l'on peut
épanouir ses propres aptitudes, ses
propres aspirations, mais au sein d'une
fraternité, d'une communauté de l'amour.
[grognement] C'est c'est pas l'égoïsme
fermé, c'est pas se fondre dans une
communauté fanatique et croyante. C'est
à la fois l'un et l'autre ensemble. Je
dirais vivez ça, c'est la vie. Allez
dans ce sens. Voilà ce que je leur
dirai.
Edgar Morin. Merci.
Voilà.